hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
talk about the idea of season 4 of Twin
Peaks I'm sure most of you have seen the
news that David Lynch didn't rule it out
continuing the series so we're gonna
look at what what he actually said and
what it actually might mean and then
we'll look at some of the stuff Kyle
MacLachlan said and laura dern said as
well before I dive into it I want to ask
you to stick around into the end I am
having a book giveaway and I am starting
a new rewatch for the first season of
Twin Peaks so I want to tell you all
about that
after I finished the main video alright
so recently David Lynch talked for the
first time about Twin Peaks after season
3 finish he was in Serbia doing a photo
exhibition called small stories and he
did a participation with some of the
people in the audience over Skype and
answered some questions not
unsurprisingly some people wanted to ask
him about Twin Peaks and when he was
asked about the fate of Audrey he said
something that pretty much applies to
the entire series he said what matters
is what you believe happened and then he
went on to say that's the whole thing
there are lots of things in life and we
wonder about them and we have to come to
our own conclusions you can for example
read a book that raises a series of
questions and you want to talk to the
author but he died a hundred years ago
that's why everything is up to you so to
put that in our own words I mean it's
just that's what it's there for is for
us to think about and he's not gonna
give any clear answers when he was asked
about the fourth season and that's
pretty much why I think in this video he
said it's too early to say he didn't
rule it out and that's the important
thing but he said that if you know
people wanted that they'd have to be
extremely patient and to say what he
said was it took him four and a half
years to write and film this season now
what does that actually mean then well
we know that Showtime has already said
that they would do it again that the
door is open to David Lynch and this was
before the season wrapped up but I don't
than anything that happened since then
has diminished their interest and I
don't think they would have said that
just to say that they don't really have
to say anything if they didn't want to
it wasn't a large commercial success for
them but it seems pretty clear that that
wasn't what they were shooting for it
gave them something that they could call
their own that was really in a league of
its own I mean this will be remembered
for a very long time and that's
something that they've always lacked I
would say even though they have some
fairly good shows on their network
certainly got them a lot of attention it
certainly gives them something to show
that they've done that's significant and
yeah I think they would do it again
would they do 18 episodes and one run
rather than two shorter seasons you know
that stuff's all for speculation we
really don't know but I think it's a
good thing that he didn't say something
to the effect of well we haven't thought
about that or you know it's really not
something that might fit in our schedule
or anything else he said that it would
take a long time and even though it's
too early to say right now he didn't
really deflect he gave an answer so
that's good
Kyle MacLachlan on the other hand before
the series started he actually had said
that he thought there could be more than
these 18 episodes after they filmed and
he said that he didn't know whether
David and Mark felt compelled to write
more you know he didn't know he couldn't
put himself inside their head but he
says that he thinks that he has more
stories meaning David Lynch after the
season ended when asked he said he would
love to do it again he says he misses
the series already they filmed this a
while ago and then it took all that time
to put together and nobody knew actually
what was going to happen so from what
Kyle MacLachlan says in the interview he
really enjoyed watching the show every
week to see how it all turned out he
also loves the character and he said
basically he would do it and he would be
happy to do it for the rest of his life
when asked about you know what does the
actual ending of it mean he said he
didn't know at all he said it's a
question like the
what year is this is a question that
just keeps asking more questions it
leaves us to go back dig through watch
and absorb and take in what we've just
seen again
and you know he basically said he's
still processing himself he knew he
filmed it he filmed it a long time ago
but he had no idea how it was actually
going to come out in the context of
everything and after seeing the finale
he said I'm still reeling reeling I
think is the word about what it all
means so he's definitely on board to do
it and his character is obviously pretty
key and Laura darn pretty much said the
same thing when I asked about whether
she would do a season four she said I'll
never say no to David and I'll never say
no to Diane because now I've fallen in
love with her so it would be impossible
for me not to want to be part of any
journey he wants to take but I think
that's what's so beautiful about his
work is that every time it ends even if
there is an ending you're just
devastated at the thought of saying
goodbye so whether he wants to dive back
into this world of Twin Peaks or go
somewhere completely different it'll be
something like we've never seen so I
thought that was a pretty good thing and
you know I can definitely relate to the
idea of not wanting to say goodbye and
I'm sure most of you guys can too and it
does sort of beg the question before the
season Kyle MacLachlan sounded pretty
sure that David Lynch had more stories
after seeing it we're all kind of
equally in the same boat of having an
idea of what we think happened but
knowing pretty certainly that we don't
know what David Lynch and Mark Frost put
together as what happened so one thing I
haven't found anywhere is anybody asking
mark frost if he would be interested in
working with it I think he is a key
component to this whole thing so not
that it would be bad obviously if David
Lynch did it by himself but I think that
if it's gonna be called Twin Peaks and
it's gonna be about Twin Peaks it would
be good to have mark frost involved with
it we do know that his books coming out
and a little over a month that's gonna
hopefully give us some more fuel for the
mystery fire I guess you could say so
yeah
I haven't found anybody asking him if he
wants to be involved but I think that
that should be a YES on his part I mean
he threw himself into this
what's the books that went along with it
and I don't know what would have
happened in season three that would make
it so that he didn't want to be involved
as far as the story goes I mean guessing
about that would be as silly as trying
to guess what was gonna happen in the
next episode of season three I mean
really they could go anywhere we have a
little time travel now a la Philip
Jeffries and we have a little bit of
alternate dimensions or something along
the lines though they certainly could
pick up with agent Cooper and I think
what people would most likely be scared
of is that a lot of the actors have
passed and we may not get a lot more of
the town of Twin Peaks but I would say
that I think that that will always be
important because especially with the
secret history and what I assume the
final dossier is going to be about the
town of Twin Peaks and the supernatural
the supernatural occurrences there the
the significance of that location for
that energy is always going to be a part
of this story obviously the Blue Rose
task force is going to be comprised of
Gordon and Tammy and agent Cooper if he
comes back so you know what I mean I
think it's always going to be tied to
the work that major Briggs did and the
things that actually happen in that part
of the world does it mean that all the
characters would play a part I don't
know you know what I mean I don't know
that that's really the next step is to
go back again but I don't think we have
to worry about it being completely
devoid of anything in the town of Twin
Peaks I think it will always have that
sort of tether and I don't think we'll
see anything more that's like a reboot
of season one or season two Laura could
still be involved I think that obviously
the lodges will still be involved but
how their role would be is kind of
confusing and it's kind of exciting to
think about really so hopefully we will
hear something that they
gonna put it into development I think we
should know by now that even if there is
a season four or multiple seasons going
forward that there will never really be
that kind of closure that we expected as
foolish as we were to expect it in the
first place so it could be just about
anything which is pretty exciting when
you think about it I do think that the
18 hour format may be a little bit hard
to sell but that's just me thinking like
I don't have any reason I mean I enjoyed
18 episodes but the time in between is
so long especially if they don't want to
give up any of the creative reins you
know what I mean like they kind of got
into a situation that they weren't happy
with working on deadline on season 2 so
you can't really see them bringing in a
bunch of directors and writers but at
the same time it takes a really long
time you know you had four and a half
years for 18 episodes last time
obviously that's not a workable timeline
to just come out every five years not
yet anyways I mean it was 25 years in
between the last one but I don't think
that's optimal by anybody's thinking so
that is basically where we're at I think
it's safe to say that most actors would
be that are still alive would be
interested in reprising it I think it
could open the door to some really
interesting stuff so let me know in the
comments what you guys think I told you
I was having a giveaway for Mark Frost's
upcoming book the final dossier everyone
who supports my patreon and who is
active on the day it comes out October
31st actually I'll pick on the first
because that's whenever patreon does its
thing so I will pick someone on that day
who is active out of a giant virtual hat
and I will send that person a copy of
the book directly to their home I'm also
getting ready to start up my
Twin Peaks I've actually watched and
took notes that I haven't made the video
yet for the season one rewatch and I
might do some live streams in relation
to that I'm looking into it right now so
I'll keep you definitely tell the
patreon patrons about that real
soon because we'll probably do a trial
with some of those guys to see if I can
get everything to work correctly so
please like this video if you liked it
make sure you subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already be sure to follow me
on Twitter and my other social media
accounts Instagram and Facebook
definitely check out my patreon and I
really want to keep doing stuff like
season one and you know I explained all
there it's just hard because it doesn't
get a lot of views because it's not
current so let's see what we can get
into in the Twin Peaks universe thanks
for watching guys I will talk to you
soon